Il est 8 heures du matin, c'est parti pour le tournage d'assassin's creed, d'assassin's creed
C'est bien ça que j'ai voulu dire hein ?
Squeezie: Sur nous ça fait un peu paysan je trouve, non ?
Squeezie : tu sais ça fait un peu une faux
Squeezie : Voilà, c'est plus le paysan stylé " aller on coupe du blé"
Donc le costume d’assassin que je porte dans le clip
c'est un costume qui a été crée par un cosplayeur amateur
Par chance ce cosplayeur a exactement les mêmes mensurations que moi, c'est à dire des mensurations de lâches
Norman : Le gros fail du costume
Le pire assassin du monde
Le mec qui a crée ce cosplay il a eu la bonne idée de mettre des petites pointes
des sortes  de  clous a l’intérieur, donc à tout mouvement : je m'ouvre la peau
Squeezie : donc moi dans le clip j'ai un peu le rôle stylé du mec " Hip-hop" qui apparaît pour faire des blagues
mais j'en ai quand même un peu ch*er a cause de ma moustache que j'ai
Tout le monde a dit "on dirait Yvick" Mister V
Norman : quasiment toute les images du clip son tournées au château Fontainebleau
L'architecture évoque pas mal l'univers d'assassin's creed
Et pour les passionnés d'histoire, c'est un château qui était l'une des demeures favorite de François premier
Mais je pense que François premier n'est jamais allé dans les endroits où on est allé
On a travaillé avec la French Freerun Family, j'ai absolument voulu faire le clip avec eux
Parce que ces mecs là déboîte, c'est vraiment hyper impressionnant ce qu'il font
Squeezie : ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que j'ai fait du parcours quand j'était petit
bon du parcour un peu amateur, mais je savais faire des flips
J'ai déjà glissé deux fois avant d'aller sur le toit, j’avais pas du tout envie de glisser sur le toit et de mourir d'un cou, cassé
Tu vois ce que je veux dire hein ? Tu vois ce que je veux dire ??
Norman : c'est la première foi que je tourne avec autant de figurant, tous habillés avec des costumes d'époque
j'ai vraiment l'impression d'être immergé dans l'univers Assassin's Creed, j'ai vraiment l'imprésion de jouer le héros quoi
limite on me poser une question je faisait "Oui qu'y a t'il ?"
Squeezie : j'avoue je me plains pour ma moustache mais Norman avait lui une fausse calvitie
qui mettait environ six fois plus de temps à être mise que ma moustache, et en plus il pouvait pas du tout bouger
Norman : c'est vrai que quand on vois les Free runners dans les vidéos faire des figures évidement c'est impressionnant
Mais on se dit qu'on peut au moins tenir debout sur un toit, ben non c'est pas possible, même être debout sur le toit c'est hyper flippant
Squeezie : quand tu montes sur les toits de Paris ça aguiche la curiosité, jusqu'au moment où tu te fais chopper par les flics
Norman : J'ai l'impression d'être un  gros hors la loi alors qu'on faisait juste une vidéo
THUG LIFE
On est quand même les hors la lois les plus gentils du monde
On leurs à montré nos vidéos et ça les a fait marrer
Déjà c'était hyper périlleux de faire un tournage sur les toits de Paris, super dangereux, flippant
En plus y'avait les concierges de l’immeuble qui gueulaient, mais ils voulaient pas juste nous faire descendre
je pense qui voulais nous faire descendre et nous tuer
On a fait aussi appel a certain cosplayeur et cosplayeuses qui sont venus avec leurs propre déguisement en fait
à la fin on a fait une sorte de grosse battle Hip-Hop puis au milieu y'avait les free runners qui faisait des figures
moi aussi j'ai fait des acrobaties assez incroyables
Evidemment ce clip c'est avant tout une chanson et la musique a été composé par Nodey il a vraiment plein de talents
En tout cas je tiens a remercier tout les gens qui ont participé a ce clip vidéo et puis évidemment Squeezie
qui a accepter de participer à ce délire
A bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo ou alors pour autre chose ou alors pour encore autre chose
A bientôt